[Music]
hey you guys
it's time for another
live stream from us
on a tuesday yeah i'm trying to get into
the show here
he's always like talking
yeah well you should put it down and
you're being on the show we need your
undivided attention the [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
juggling with
yeah i know the feeling but you gotta
like concentrate on um we saw exorcist
the beginning
last night this was so confusing you
guys okay so we just like i just picked
this at random i was scrolling through
tubie and i was just kind of like well
we need a movie you haven't seen before
they have a lot of good horror movies on
2b but we've already reviewed most of
them so i'm kind of scrolling through
them scrolling through and i was kind of
like oh there's like a few possibilities
and then i was like oh exercise at the
beginning i was like did we see that
i was like
wait i don't think we saw that and it's
like i'm pretty sure we didn't review
that so i told him about it he's like
okay let's watch that
so we start watching it
and i told him i said
this movie doesn't seem familiar
but the main actor stellen skarsgard
playing father marin
is very familiar and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on i'm like did i just see
this movie and i just completely forgot
about it so we started doing a little
bit of sleuthing
and i think this is the first time this
has ever happened in the history of
hollywood
yeah the first movie that they made
which was directed by paul schrader was
dominion
uh prequel to the exorcist which is like
the dumbest subtitle of all time
that was the movie that we saw yeah um i
don't remember if we reviewed it or not
but we for sure saw it like a couple
like probably a year or two ago
and the same actor played father marin
so
they did dominion
and i guess
the
studio heads saw it and were like this
kind of sucks i don't think this is
gonna fly
so they fired the director
hired renny harlan
and said redo this movie
they used a little bit of the footage
from dominion
but it's like
kind of the same story they like moved a
few things around
because i think it's based on didn't
william peter blatty write a book called
dominion that was kind of like prickly i
can't you're asking me um i think he did
but so i think it's kind of loosely
based on that so the story is kind of
similar and like i said stellen
skarsgard is in both of them playing
father marin but every all the other
actors are different so they changed the
story up and rewrote because i guess
what happened was paul schrader's
version which we did see and i remember
it being okay but i don't really
remember that much about it i remember
liking it yeah it was all right um i
think that the reason the executives
didn't like it was because they thought
well it wasn't horrory enough
um so when reni harlan like came in they
said horror it up some
um so
that's what he did but then like they
released renny harlan's version this one
exorcist the beginning and it tanked and
it got like super really really bad
reviews also
and so then
they gave paul schrader
like a bunch of money and said hey
finish up dominion and we'll release
that one too
like even though it's essentially the
same movie
and then they released that one and that
one didn't do good either yeah although
it did it seemed to get slightly better
reviews
but
it still like was it still tanked at the
box office they spent like 80 million
dollars making essentially two movies
that are they're not exactly the same
but they're very very similar like the
story is similar yeah this one when it
got it when it came out was pretty much
universally panned it got razzies and
stuff and it flopped
um
but i liked it [ __ ] them
i didn't mind it it's it's kind of a
classy feeling movie
it's real well made the writing's real
good the acting's really good
but i see why they gave it a razzy at
the very end in the final [ __ ]
exorcist kind of
fight between the damn demon
it does kind of lose its cool a little
bit it kind of fell off the cliff of
cheese yeah a little cheesy
and it was totally um
it [ __ ] up it was totally different
from the tone of the rest of the movie
which was kind of serious kind of almost
kind of grounded in reality to a certain
extent
or you know they were trying to make you
believe this really happened some
supernatural [ __ ]
and it gets to the end and it gets
[ __ ] wild but a lot of it is just the
score that was happening in the
background and edit it could have easily
been fixed by showing less
and they just cut some [ __ ] out of it
a couple just a couple seconds out of
the end yeah out of the end and change
the music i don't think
i think people would have liked it a lot
better because honestly the whole time
we were watching it like oscar just said
dominion is more eerie than this one
yeah i kind of feel like dominion
was like a more serious movie whereas
like i said this one they specifically
said we need more horror and it does
have that there is a lot more like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in it and
in you know a bunch of kids getting
killed and babies covered with maggots
and [ __ ] like that so there's a bunch of
that kind of stuff but i think that from
what i remember
dominion was more tonally consistent
this one was kind of had the same tone
to it like being
serious like you know a very serious
film but then at the end i think it went
way too far into
the horror redirection where it almost
became like i don't want to say it
almost became funny
but it would just teetered like on that
light i think they should have just
rained that in a little bit i did like
that they tried to tie it in with the
original exorcist at the end
with the woman getting possessed because
i think in dominion the little kid was
possessed because that goes back to
uh the lore in the book and [ __ ] like
that of uh father maron like treating a
little african boy
so in dominion it actually was a boy
but then in this version they switched
it up and made it the woman the doctor
and she was the one possessed and i like
that they tried to tie it in with the
original exorcist by giving her like the
you know the linda blair the pazuzu
makeup and like a voice similar to that
and have her like spewing profanities
and stuff like linda blair didn't the
original one but
i see where they were going with that
but the problem is that the exorcist is
so culturally ubiquitous
and has been parodied so many times
that i don't know if you can do that
without it coming off a little bit like
a parody yep it never should have had
had a girl or that woman be possessed it
should have been a man
should have been bigger
and more intimidating and even more evil
because there's no way you're going to
be able to [ __ ]
redo what happened with linda blair you
just you have to go in the opposite
direction
yeah i mean because back then like i
said it was scary back then but but
everybody in their mom has seen that
movie that already and it's been
paradise [ __ ] even linda blair was in a
parody called repossessed with leslie
leslie nielsen where she was doing a
parody of that character like in the i
think it was the early 80s yeah so the
priest should have been possessed or one
of the guys on the dig should have been
possessed and he should have gotten
[ __ ] big and intimidating
like i'm just a big old male demon you
know that's what they should have should
have done
you can't possess that many women in a
row but here's the here's the thing it
was better than exorcist two
i kind of i feel like most movies are
better
well the thing about it is that exorcist
two
i guess when they made dominion and
slash the beginning
they said cause in exorcist two i think
they mention and this might have been
from the novel too i haven't read the
novel in a long time
but in exorcist two father marin like
they mentioned that father marin had
chased the same demon out of a kid like
i said his name was kokomo or something
like that like like an african boy
in 1935
now that is not consistent with the
story in this one like in dominion he
does go to africa but i think it's 1949
it's after world war ii right yeah
um yeah because there's a thing about
nazi concentration camps in there so i
think it's after world war ii
and so he goes there and in dominion he
does chase the uh the demon out of a kid
but his name's not kokomo
and in the second one like there's a kid
that you think is possessed by a demon
his name's not kokomo either but uh it's
kind of like a red herring and then it
turns out that the doctor woman was
possessed the whole time because i guess
they wanted to switch it up so it wasn't
exactly the same as the other one so it
would be like hey i already saw this
movie maybe that did happen in 35 we
weren't in 35 we were 45 it was 1949 49
it was 1949. so maybe there's a prequel
to the prequel
somebody still needs to make that movie
right yeah they're talking about a
completely different kid it just like so
happened thank you zack the
cinematographer on both versions was
vittorio storaro who did apocalypse now
and last emperor and a lot of giallo and
even this looks crappy compared to his
usual work which is kind of sad
it's not that bad though and honestly i
had forgotten
i knew that uh i knew ronnie harlan's
name i remember that he was married to
gina davis back in the day i remember
that and he did that movie with her as a
pirate that kind of tanked but then i i
was like what else did he i know that he
directed like a [ __ ] ton of stuff so i
looked him up and he did uh nightmare on
elm street four the dream master uh
adventures of ford fairlane do you
remember that one
uh with [ __ ] what's that fucker's
name that comedian i don't know die hard
too
um
uh cliffhanger yeah long case night and
deep blue sea which i remember was okay
you just been talking about that
comedian guy who pretended to be a guido
yeah yeah yeah yeah what the [ __ ] was
that dude's name
i don't know he was a flashlight japan
yeah well yeah i remember well it was a
long flash i remember but it's like i
can't remember his name what's his
[ __ ] name i don't know i can see his
face and hear his voice i just can't
place i can't think of his name
andrew dice clay thank you there you go
that's it
getting old it sucks folks
it doesn't work
yeah
um but yeah so like i said it's not
crazy because
even the original movie and the original
novel
you know father marin comes in and he's
old
and he hints around that he's had this
fascinating history and he's encountered
this demon before
so this seems like ready made for a
prequel so it wasn't like a dumb idea it
wasn't like they were you know what i
mean and it would you know and i think
it's like an interesting story to
explore so if you haven't seen this
movie what happens in it like i said
it's set in 1949
father marin
uh has actually lost his faith he was a
priest and then he says [ __ ] the
priesthood after uh i guess he was in
the netherlands and like the nazis
occupied and he ended up
having to like this guy came and like
made him pick like the people in the
town that he would shoot so otherwise
they would shoot the whole thing and so
he's like so guilty about it he's like
where was god during all that [ __ ] the
priesthood like i said so he decides i'm
gonna go be an archaeologist instead
and then he gets hired to go to this
place in uh near nairobi in kenya
and they're like we found this weirdest
[ __ ] thing that's like a christian
church
but it's like way older than that was
like 1500 years old and it's like way
before the christians got there and we
can't figure out why it's there and some
of the statues in there are weird and
then it's like almost like new and then
they buried it
so they're like you need to go check
that out so he goes
and he's with this younger priest from
the vatican
who
seems to know some [ __ ] that's going on
even though he says that he doesn't know
what's going on
but it's like really weird there's like
all there's all these like graves and
they say like oh all these people died
of a plague and he goes down into the
church and
he's like the statues in there it seems
kind of sort of like a christian church
from that era but then he's like all the
statues
um like the angels all have weapons that
are pointing downward and then
somebody's been in there and they hung
like the jesus on the cross thing like
they hung it upside down like from the
ceiling and then like all the
locals
are
think the place is cursed it's like they
can't get some of the diggers like the
dude that was running the um the the
what you call it the dig
he went nuts and they had to send him to
like a sanitarium
and there's all this kind of crazy [ __ ]
happening and you know so father marin
is like obviously like i said lost his
faith he doesn't believe this is demonic
he just thinks that you know he he
doesn't think all this crazy shit's
going on he meets this woman that's a
doctor and she's trying to help him all
out but
you know they're
quote unquote superstitious even though
it turns out they're not superstitious
because there really is an actual demon
so um and then he goes like underneath
the church and they find that i like
that they used the same statue
the same pazuzu statue that was from the
original movie like he finds it like
underneath the ground
so this this like the movie like you
said i you do kind of have to pay
attention to it because the story is you
said the story was a little convoluted
yeah a little bit which it is kind of
but i mean you can keep up with it if
you kind of pay attention to like all
the stuff but a lot of stuff does happen
in it and you have to kind of like
listen to a lot of the conversations
because there's a lot of [ __ ] about
but you know what the upshot of it is
and i don't remember if they mentioned
this in dominion or not but it is
mentioned in exorcist the beginning
that this church
was built on top of the place
that they believed that that's where
lucifer fell from heaven
i don't know if they brought that up and
demanded it's like a legend they were
trying to confirm it yeah so it's like
this is like the evilest place ever and
so they had to slap so there was like a
the pazuzu shrine down there and then
the church came it's like we gotta slap
this church on top of this [ __ ] because
we gotta seal in that evil you know what
i mean like some spiritual tupperware
action so they're trying to seal it down
under the earth
and then they buried that church just
for like extra
i don't know like extra protection i
guess but then these uh these [ __ ]
archaeologists came along and said hey
let's dig it up
and all the local people are like no
you're gonna release all the curse and
that's exactly what happens like
pete like there's all kind of um
like a plague kind of thing starts like
that one character
is he like was he like the second in
command of the dig because the guy that
was the head of the dig
he like went crazy right and started
drawing pazuzu on everything and then
they had to send him to like the mental
hospital
and then there's this other guy who's
perpetually drunk and has like boils all
over his face and is constantly trying
to mack all over this
uh this doctor woman who is just kind of
like way too nice to him i think but i
don't know
she's like she's just kind of i think
she was
they were kind of getting off the con
almost borderline frenemies because they
were working together too so she yeah
she was kind of laughing
joe you know laughing it off
she's like well he's so drunk i could
probably just like push him over if he
gets like he's trying to get
[Music]
sulfuric acid perhaps
i mean that's what i would have said but
because you know but she didn't say that
she was just kind of like oh you're so
funny and i was just kind of like well i
mean you know and i guess it was set in
1949 and you had to put up with a lot of
[ __ ] back then you couldn't really
lay fire you're still putting it on now
going out of the backer bar they're
still doing that no i know i'm just
saying that
baby i tell you what this and this is i
could never you'd never handle this i
got on that and break it you know they
should like they just give it right back
and like
you know that's
no i'm just saying that she she didn't
say anything about looking and they're
ugly that's the difference
no i was saying that she didn't say
anything back to her maybe well maybe
because she thought like she this is her
job at this dig and she didn't want to
like cause trouble i don't know but um
but yeah so
and he gets like grosser and grosser
like as so i will say that rennie harlan
he did like you know they told him
you know inject some more horror into
this story and he did do that i mean
there's uh there's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happens in this like a little kid gets
torn apart by hyenas
they're kind of bad cgi hyenas but
hyenas nonetheless and he does get like
pretty graphically torn apart so there's
that a little kid gets shot in the head
by nazis at point blank range so there's
that
um and then turns up as kind of like a
vision or a ghost like later on
uh you get to see a baby get born that's
dead and that has maggots all over it so
there's that too
so you know it's pretty uh it's pretty
gory and i think and actually like the
drunk guy
with the boyle face
what the [ __ ]
oh he oh that's right they find him
well they find his teeth
right they go in the bar
and he was like uh you know killed by
something like you don't see what it is
he just turns around and goes oh [ __ ]
you know what i mean and then like they
find later
some of his teeth like embedded
in the top of the bar almost as if he
like was biting or something like that
and somebody like pulled him away and
then later on they go into the
underground church thing which actually
they've dug out so it's not underground
anymore
but they find him in there
and somebody
has basically like hollowed him out like
he's like it's almost kind of like you
remember that scene in silence of the
lambs where um where anthony hopkins
like escaped from the thing and he took
that cop and did the big he just like
took all his [ __ ] guts out and like
hung him up on the on the [ __ ] like up
by the ceiling it looked kind of like
that but actually even gorier because
it's just
it's just like the middle of his tummy
was just like a big [ __ ] hole and
it's just like all dripping and
everything like that so
there is like a lot more gore in this
but like i said toward the end
when you have kind of like the big
battle
of father marin finally
getting his faith back now that he
actually like finally gets to the point
where he's like okay this demon [ __ ] is
real and he's also started to develop
some feelings for this doctor
and
when he finds out like he kind of
deduces that actually she was the one
that was low-key possessed the whole
time and they were just they were like
making you think that it was the kid or
the demon was making you think that it
was the kid you know what i'm saying
yeah but it was actually like the doctor
the whole time
so he actually like gets his faith back
and does like the battle with the
you know with the demon and like i said
i did like that they sort of made like a
callback to the linda blair pazuzu thing
because like the makeup looks similar
and it look and it looks good i thought
like the you know with the yellow eyes
and the scratches on the face and
everything like that and she has like
the voice and she says some of the same
kind of stuff
but
like i said i kind of wish they had
reigned that in a little bit because
they do have a thing where she like
you know climbs all over the cave walls
and they do it like in cgi and it
doesn't load it was 2004
so
a lot of cgi from 2004 hasn't aged all
that well it all looked bad it all yeah
so it wasn't just this movie i'm not
just picking on this movie um because
like i said the
you know the um
the hyenas in this are cgi also and they
also look crappy but
you know in 2004 it was really difficult
to do
furry animals
that looked realistic so i'm not gonna
like [ __ ] on it too much but i do kind
of wish that they had just like
i don't know because i i didn't mind
that i didn't mind that idea
but
and i think in particular the very last
sequence where she was like running at
him
like down that cave like the you know
the corridor or whatever
and you know he was like yelling at you
know yelling the prayers at her
and it was kind of like green screened
and weird and it's just like they kept
like doing a close-up of him like
yelling the prayers and then she was
kind of like coming at him with
the hair and it was kind of fakey
looking and
it's i i when we got to that point
because up to the up to that point we
were like i wonder why this movie gets
like [ __ ] on so much this isn't bad it's
like i've seen a million worse but then
we got to that scene i'm like oh okay
now i think i see what they're talking
about
but it was just the very last part in
the final 10 minutes there's uh
there's a tonal shift that the movie
doesn't recover from and it didn't and
it ends kind of like on up notes and
[ __ ] and you're like uh that's this
movie this shouldn't it ended like that
it should have been pretty dark through
the whole through the whole movie
but
it's just
it could be fixed they just didn't
yeah because most of it is fine yeah um
really the only part that made me think
oh now i see what everybody's talking
about was like the last five minutes
yeah and it was only a few seconds of
footage and um
improper uh score that
which [ __ ] up the tone
yeah because it had been very serious up
to that like a serious move like i said
it had some [ __ ] up horror [ __ ]
happened in it it wasn't [ __ ] around
you know it killed a bunch of kids it
was real bloody and uh but it was still
like a serious movie that was like you
know going into like serious [ __ ] and
the acting was really good and
everything like that it just went too
far
in the cheesy direction like right at
the end and then it went kind of a
little bit like sappy yeah like right
but it was right at the end it was right
at the end so like i said if that could
be re-edited very easily the rest of it
was totally fine i don't know why they
did that i don't know either uh oscar
said i always wondered about that scene
why did that guy develop boils on his
face before he died see i'm not sure
yeah i'm not sure it was adequately
explained but i assumed
that because like ever since because he
was kind of one of the main guys that
was going in and out of the church
um
i thought that proximity to the church
was gonna give you like some effects of
demon possession because it's like some
of the other diggers and stuff like that
that like the locals like a couple of
them had like epileptic seizures and
[ __ ] like that and like i said that baby
was born that was dead and had maggots
all over it so i just assumed that like
the evil was like seeping out into the
area and because
he had gone into
the church maybe more than anybody like
he got affected more than anyone else
did
because like i said they
there was a story that like oh all these
people here like all these graves or
whatever all these people died of plague
which turned out not to be true but one
of the locals says to father marin it
wasn't a plague it's like it was
demon [ __ ] and that's what's going on
right now you know but you know
everybody just said it was a plague
because that's what they thought it was
so i'm guessing that it was demon [ __ ]
but because it was boils and stuff
everyone just said it was a plague so
that's what i thought i don't think they
explained it but that's what i was
assuming you know what i'm saying
um
granthar says grantham's joke of the day
it takes 100 nails to make a crib but
only one screw to make a baby that's
right
that's such a dad joke
is that a dad joke i guess technically
yeah raptors is also saying that they
see if there's a video of a tank [ __ ]
blowing up a dude in ukraine it's not
one dude it's a bunch of dudes
they come up they're some improvised
infantry unit they come out walk out
into the open they see a russian tank
they think it's ukrainian tank and tank
bears down on them when any personnel
around blows them all up kills about it
kills about seven or eight of them they
look like
they're getting ready to attack dunbass
or they cut the russian troops have come
out of refit they were resting for
four or five days
putting [ __ ] back together and they're
getting ready to hit done bastard the
next couple days it's going to be wild
granthar says speaking of perpetually
drunk tomorrow morning granthar is
flagged to bend oregon for the funeral
of a buddy who drank himself to death at
age 51.
jesus christ
we were talking about
we were talking about someone one of
your relatives that drank himself to
death that was my uncle yeah
that was my dad's sister's um husband we
were just talking about that the other
day
he was uh
yeah trained himself to death on purpose
he got uh they retired and from his job
they made him take retirement they got
sick of his jokes
he's posting racy jokes and [ __ ] that
went over real well about the 70s or 80s
but
looking in the 2000s they're like no no
we can't have that around the [ __ ] he
worked in a refinery oil refinery dinner
and um
they made him take his retirement and he
went home and says [ __ ] it the kids are
gone raised and my job's gone i'm just
gonna take this check if i could drink
myself to death he went to the hospital
two or three times and said you're
drinking yourself to death you you leave
me alone i do what i want to do so you
got another girlfriend [ __ ] my house
yeah he got another girlfriend moved out
of the house moved moved into the camper
that was in the backyard he and his
girlfriend was a bum
and uh they stayed up in there and drank
until he died
and then well i guess now i kicked the
bum out everybody's gotta have hobbies
yeah you gotta get out of here yeah nice
to find somebody to share your hobbies
yeah
[ __ ] well they hadn't really they hadn't
really been together in decades anyway
and
he
he was so drunk he couldn't he couldn't
sleep with that bomb they were just
friends drinking buddies
living in that damn camper that's right
just sharing hobbies yeah
he was funny though man i like to know
his michael wilson oscar said he went
out doing what i wanted that's exactly
what i said yeah but i was talking to
him yeah
i was like well i guess he went out
doing what he loved that's something
yeah wilson was an alcoholic uh he was
he's born an alcoholic but he he got off
of the booze so he could complete his
career he raised his children he did it
that for like 20 something years
and then [ __ ] when that job was gone
and the kids are gone he's like [ __ ] it
i'm going back to drinking he literally
drank himself to death knowing he was
drinking himself to death
just like nicolas cage leaving las vegas
yeah
yeah
he was checking out he was sick of it
well i guess there's worse ways to go
um you know i figured he was old and he
didn't really have anything to look
forward to so he's just gonna he's gonna
[ __ ] get high and get the [ __ ] out of
here
everything was paid for slasher fred
said in the original there's a dream
that father charis has about his mother
yeah i kind of wish
did they ever make anything about father
charis because he's kind of an
interesting character as well but it
seems like it's always about father
marin i guess because father marin
came into the exorcist already an old
guy even though i think max von sydei
was only 40 something when he shot that
they put like old age makeup on him but
he came in as an old guy like with
supposedly storied history and
mysterious history and stuff so i can
see how there's like a lot more to mine
there because i do kind of feel like
father charis they did kind of give
someone more of his backstory because
the kind of i feel like the exorcist was
kind of yes it's about the possession
yes it was about linda blair but it's
kind of about father terrace too you
know what i mean um
jason says these prequels should not end
on a positive no we all know what
happens in iraq yeah it's like it wasn't
so much that this ended on a positive
note it was like well i mean because the
i mean spoiler alert but the woman that
was possessed she dies
so he can't he doesn't save her like i
guess he gets the demon out her but she
dies anyway
and so
you know i'm guessing because that's the
thing he like battles this demon and i
guess he defeats it for a while and it
goes into stasis
and then it like pops back up at
inopportune times and it's like i'm
gonna go [ __ ] with that priest again
just for shits and giggles i just think
that
i know how studios are i mean they came
out with the exorcist it was a huge hit
they're like we got to make another one
because we'll we'll make money
but artistically they should have just
they should have just shut the [ __ ] up
after that first one you just don't talk
about this ever again you just let that
[ __ ] because that is a classic movie
it's [ __ ] epic
yeah and it didn't need a sequel
necessarily and it didn't need a prequel
it told you everything it needed to tell
you and and still keep you in wonderment
damn
you know what i mean the more you talk
about that the less scary it's going to
be yeah everything doesn't have to be
like overexplained but like i said i
know just like terminator
yeah i mean i know why they do it like i
said well you liked this this made
a bajillion dollars so we're gonna make
even more money like but and people
still go see them so they're not wrong
it's very very rare that sequels work
out i will say
even though you can say like the extras
didn't need a prequel i would argue that
if you're gonna make anything i think a
prequel would have been a is a better
idea than a sequel
because like i said father marin he's a
character that was introduced you didn't
know a lot about his backstory but they
just hinted at it and you know there's
something you could explore there where
you spot the demo before that's a good
idea so i don't mind you know the idea
of a prequel but i will say though
that
the prequels of both dominion and
exorcist the beginning were for sure uh
about a hundred times better than
exorcist ii the heretic
that's for goddamn sure even though that
was that [ __ ] was was a [ __ ] show that
sometimes was
decent to watch just to see [ __ ]
richard burton's [ __ ] drunk ass
mumble his way through
with that [ __ ] machine on his head
and [ __ ] him doing the hypnosis and
that was another movie that was like
simultaneously really really ridiculous
and really really boring yeah it kind of
was you know what i mean
they tried to go somewhere new with it
but no
most most sequels are cash grabs
yeah it's very rare that it works out
um the back to the futures
trilogy worked
uh the star wars original three even the
prequels weren't that bad but the
original three would work
um
well because that's a much more sharp
stuff working i mean stuff like that's a
much more expansive story that's a much
more epic
i mean the exorcist was essentially
about a girl getting possessed and you
know a priest like getting their faith
back and blah blah blah this is a
smaller story so that doesn't really
need to be expanded to any great degree
there really should have been only a
couple of those predators
movies a couple of them now i've watched
them did you man
predator and predators when they're on
the alien planet those that's the best
ones the avp ones were okay
um i liked predators better than the avp
movies yeah yeah predator one and
predators
yeah [ __ ] are
are good movies real good the first
one's just great though you know um
robocop one and two
two was pretty good too um
terminator should have only been
terminator one there should not have
been a terminator too some people were
like what what yeah there should go back
and watch terminator 2 with the
skeptical eye and it's it's a great
action movie but it is not it is not the
horror movie terminator 1 was
um terminator 1 was classic they should
have just left it like that you
shouldn't have known anything more about
the other timelines not none of that
expand don't expand that [ __ ] just
stew in it just go damn what about it
damn yeah that's what you were meant to
do you weren't meant to see the future
and all that [ __ ]
and meet skynet and then be disappointed
you know that was never supposed to
happen
well yeah i mean we've talked about this
a lot it's like a lot of times
particularly with horror yeah um
you know the more you leave [ __ ] alone
the more you leave things to people's
imagination i think the more fondly it's
remembered
uh because you don't need to over
explain everything yeah the alien
franchise alien one and two
blade runner
prometheus one and prometheus two which
they called aliens four or some [ __ ]
like that those kind of work
uh some a lot of that other [ __ ] didn't
work out of that it's just
it's sad but it's true
uh because alien 3 didn't really work
it kind and it wasn't a bad movie
it was made it was made pretty well
it's just
not what they needed and it's just
the way it ended was not very good and
and then the one sigourney weaver made
[ __ ] alien 4 was kind of it was kind
of an over top over the top slapstick
version of aliens it's almost oh even
though it had some great moments in it
it did it had some great ideas in it but
it was still kind of like
the escape from la of the alien series
um
which see there should have never been
an escape from la it should have just
been escaped from new york and leave it
the [ __ ] alone all right
well yeah because did good i mean the
premise of escape from new york is kind
of a one-and-done it's a one-and-done
it's not like it's not like that uh set
of circumstances is ever gonna happen
again like to in that same way right
it's just strange credulity you know
what i mean he should have done
something else
uh slasher fred said i love the exorcist
theme tubular bells i do as well my dad
had it on vinyl back in the old days
mike oldfield and uh he used to listen
to that all the time and i thought that
was really really cool now i will say
though that i really really like uh and
we've reviewed it and talked about a lot
of times if you haven't seen it exorcist
three
is great
because it goes father karis is in it
but sort of um but it does a different
thing it's almost more like a murder
mystery
and
it doesn't really do it has an exorcism
because they made him put an exorcism in
there but it's not really about that
it's more like a murder mystery and i
kind of like that because they went like
in a little sideways with it and i
thought that was cooler i'm i'm gonna
tell you how snake pliskin fans escaped
from new york she had some secret
there's a there's a movie out there i
think it's called lockout or lockdown
and it really it really should have been
called escape from escape from outer
space it was going to be a [ __ ] snake
plastic movie how can you escape from
outer space outer space is kind of like
everywhere they had an orbital
orbital space station that was a plan
that was a um that was a an orbital
prison
and snake pliskin gets sent to it and
they uh capture some girl that she's
like the president's daughter type of
deal again and he's got again
she's some kind of hostage and he he
gets sent to this prison on a secret
mission basically to go rescue that
prisoner and come out of there and
escape from outer space and come back
it's going to be it was some i think it
was called lockout or lockdown it had um
it had the dude that played wayland and
[ __ ] prometheus what's that guy's
name
um
he's a pretty famous actor i know you're
talking about i just can't think of it
what that guy's name is
and uh
but i guess they couldn't get crustled
to do it russell might have been a
little too old at the time but uh that
should have been yeah crus was playing
santa claus he's playing at santa claus
this is i think uh 2000 in in the year
2000 i think that's when that movie came
out lockdown or lockout or something
pierce what's his name pierce no no
no because that guy's name is
hi pierce yeah guy pierce
yeah he's in it you know it's really
weird that you mentioned guy pierce
because for some reason today i randomly
thought of the adventures of priscilla
queen of the desert yeah and i was like
man i need to watch that movie again i
love that movie i think i'm on a dvd
somewhere and guy pierce is in that as
well yeah yeah it says it's called
lockout yeah lockout is good
and it's a that's a snake pliskin movie
they just couldn't get the light they
just couldn't get permission to call it
call it snake blizzkit you know but
that's what it is did you show me that
movie that sounds kind of i think you've
watched it once i don't remember a guy
that's pretty good about it it's pretty
good it did have a little bit of cheese
in it it like had some violent comedy in
it
uh but it wasn't as cheesy as a
[ __ ] escape from l.a
which escaped from l.a had some good
ideas in it
it's just that the tone was a little
wrong it was a little tuesday it also
had a lot of really bad ideas
it was it was very
very much a comic book movie
but that was that was not the tone of
[ __ ] escape escape from new york it
was it's kind of serious you know it's
pretty good
oscar says your dad played tubular bells
on vinyl that explains a lot jenny it
does doesn't it but yeah that's keys to
play that all the time um lars ulrich
says it has to be said uh max von sydow
and stellen skarsgard who played uh
father merritt and this are both from
good old sweden that's what i was and i
was thinking that too while i was
watching the movie i said how that's
really cool that they actually did get a
swedish actor because max von said i was
swedish um so it's cool that they
actually got a swedish actor to play him
instead of like somebody doing like a
fakey swedish accent i was like that's
nice so at least they put that much
thought into it
you know what i mean yeah
you know what i think because i saw max
von sydow like in the extras when i was
a kid i didn't realize until i was
probably a teenager that max von said i
was swedish and it actually been in all
those like ingmar bergman movies
which uh my favorite of which is hour of
the wolf if you guys have ever seen that
one that movie's creepy as [ __ ] if you
like david lynch movies and you want to
see where like david lynch got some of
his weirdness from
that movie is a good place to start
because there's like a lot of weird
lynchian [ __ ] in there
uh oscar says guy pierce is underrated
he really is i mean he's a good actor
like i said i loved him in priscilla
queen of the desert is this an abba turd
um yeah that you'll you'll if you see
that movie you know i'm talking about
and uh also what was the other one oh
memento have you seen did you see
memento
the movie that was like it's like a
murder mystery but it's in backwards
order christopher nolan directed it
you'd probably like it that was actually
that was actually the first words i
don't know no well it's not backwards
it's
the scenes are in reverse order
because the guy has
uh that memory thing where you can't
form new memories yeah
so he keeps for no it's not it's really
really good seriously it's done really
really well um that was actually kind of
the first movie that brought christopher
nolan to like wider like in a wider
audience because everybody loved that
movie so much yeah jason uh solid snake
from metal gear yeah that that that
actually is a direct ripoff of [ __ ]
snake whisking that's who they're
talking about
metal gear metal gear was when that
first metal gear came out it was
basically a ripoff escape from new york
basically
tammy says guy pierce plays a great
baddie in lawless uh tom hardy movie
about moonshiners yeah you brought that
up before i wrote it down we just
haven't gotten around to watching it yet
okay but yeah we got to see that one
because man tom hardy and guy pierce
yeah we got to see that hugo says
lawless hugo said memento is awesome
oscar said tom would consider momento a
masterpiece yeah see i think he would i
know when i say it like oh it's in
reverse order you'd be like oh that'll
drive me it's really not that hard to
figure out i promise
um it's actually it's it's actually
really really good it's a good it's a
good story i haven't seen it a long time
but i remember really liking it a lot so
um yeah so exorcist the beginning
it's on to be it's not bad it's actually
yeah well here's the thing it got
nominated did it win it didn't win any
golden raspberry or razzies or whatever
they call them
i didn't win but it got nominated
and then i was wondering to myself
i was if this was a movie that got
nominated for a razzy in 2004 did the
razzies only
nominate like big studio films because i
was like i for sure could think of like
a lot of really really shitty like indie
movies like from 2004 that were way
worse than this for christ's sake like
the old catwoman movie that got a razzy
well that was pretty that was bad that
was it wasn't as bad as they said it was
well no but it was worse than this it
was worse than actually the beginning
i did not like that catwoman movie
that movie yeah whatever but the thing
about it was like part of the problem
with the catwoman movie was the costume
the costume looked [ __ ] stupid
uh yeah it did have some stupid
some stupid [ __ ] plot elements
but man a lot of a lot of superhero
movies are [ __ ] stupid a lot of them
that's true i mean i'm willing to give
movies a lot of leeway because honestly
i like bad movies as long as they
entertain me i don't give a [ __ ] if it's
stupid or not but it's like
i don't know like i said the worst thing
a movie can be is boring or like not
entertaining if you're entertaining me
whether it's good or bad then i'm all
for it
um i'm just saying that the razzies it
seems to me that movies that i've seen
that got nominated for razzies i think
they kind of just stick to big studio
pictures because i guess they would
because it's like they don't want to
nominate like a bunch of random ass like
indie movies that nobody's heard of no
it's got to be something we spend a lot
of money on yeah i mean they kind of
want like and plus they probably want
the name recognition or nobody would
like to talk
you know
yeah because you spend like 100 million
dollars on something how can that suck
right yeah that sucks and it sucks like
cats
how bad cats was
that was just a poorly conceived
idea i mean it wasn't a bad idea because
you could see like that [ __ ] musical
has run like since
dinosaurs roam the earth and like it's
made all the money in the world and
everybody's horrible but then they make
it so there's like a movie version
doesn't sound crazy on its face
but i think i don't think the problem
was the idea it was just the execution
well it was just too uncanny valley that
and nobody nobody showed up to see it
that's a big thing of it too it's just
nobody get nobody gives a [ __ ] about
that or the movie the movie going
audience doesn't give a [ __ ] about cats
yeah that's more that's more a theater
experience i feel like it didn't really
translate show that to tourists old
tourists that come to new york i mean
some musicals work well in movie form
obviously but that was definitely not
one of them i think
i think they think they tried to sell
[ __ ] that musical that was his name
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] west side story recently
and that bobbed
and that was that was [ __ ] george
lucas or no it's steven spielberg
although i heard it was actually really
good yeah but nobody sees it nobody sees
it i wouldn't mind seeing that i liked
the original i like the original west
side story just something you watch on
the xbox
yeah i don't know if i'd go to a theater
and see it but i wouldn't mind seeing it
because i liked the original a lot yeah
they just said they evidently you know
i like where i was gonna go see uh the
batman but i'm sorry [ __ ] it that'll be
on tv in another month
although we're still paying for that
[ __ ] theater thing i mean we might as
well go see some [ __ ] it's otherwise
it's like a waste of money we just
haven't had time yeah i still want to
see that x movie yeah that horror movie
did that but did that black phone movie
ever come out i don't know
i kind of wanted to see that that
blumhouse one yeah emc just makes money
of people having the app and forgetting
the show and forgetting to show up yeah
well it's a it's more of a hassle now
because it's farther yeah you know what
i mean i mean before it only took like
10-15 minutes to drive there now it's
like a whole ordeal like it's just like
like 40 minutes or something it's all
surface streets yeah because that's the
it's still the closest
we moved this far away and that's still
the closest movie theater
well what's funny is that we're we get
we're bitching about it it's only 12
miles farther than it was i know but it
seems like it seems like that's only 12
miles per hour it seems a lot farther
yeah that's all i'm saying yeah all
right so i guess we'll wrap it up for
today so tomorrow's main show and i'm
sure everybody will be excited because
we're talking about that uh jimmy jimmy
seville seville seville however you
pronounce his last name the uh you know
that british television personality that
they found out was a perv after he died
well they they he kind of knew he was a
perv before but he didn't get caught for
nothing till like after he john johnny
rotten newton well a lot of people knew
like i said a lot of people knew there
was like all kind of rumors they just
didn't have any proof but yeah so we're
gonna do like dermot sent me a whole
bunch of um
uh
documentaries about it bye
i'm shutting it down
dermot sent me a whole bunch of like
documentary let's go ahead and do
another show documentaries about it no i
was just finishing up okay you're so
rude she just like gets up and leaves
yeah it's even like you don't like say
bye to anybody or anything he's just
like i'm just watered up probably gonna
be back on here tomorrow
how do you know you might get hit by an
asteroid tomorrow you're struck by
lightning yeah you don't know
anyway so yeah we'll be back tomorrow
talking about that uh perverted british
dude so uh thanks everybody for dropping
by thanks for super chat and we'll see
you guys again tomorrow evening
bye